It'll be really great if we could draw the graph of Athena's function, and we
are actually really close to being able to do that. First however, I'd like to
know what domain makes sense for the concert hall situation. This is the
original equation we had, written in a slightly different form, since I've
Factored out a two from both the numerator and the denominator. It's important
to remember here what our variables stand for. T of course is the reverberation
time, measured in seconds as a matter of fact. And X here more importantly,
stands for the depth of the stage in the concert hall measured in feet. So what
restrictions based on what x stands for, do we need to place on the values of
x, or on the domain? Use your common sense here.